welcome to this video we call kar 1985
again that's a really frequent now can I
do something let's go g3 maybe it's this
can be six I believe No okay let's go to
something else let's go for the ready
gambler team it's an interesting opening
line that I've played quite a bit sync
91 developers taken for these free later
yeah wyd usually has very decent
compensation in this position C takes 93
for later central play and blacks on
blacks whole um coincide is weakened
okay so he doesn't want to want to take
I can play 94 now Bishop e3 is also move
it's also efore but that looks a bit
wrong I wonder what Bishop b3 if this is
any good 95 prompting him to move again
maybe let's try that night bd5 I guess
and 94
93 I can't even think about taking with
the pawn okay if I go back now maybe I
can go back it's also a 4 in this
position yeah and I have some tech tech
CIF Bishop takes you six tactics based
based on my development Knight b6 rupee
eight Bishop takes c6 takes tanks set
working there's also Knight f3 by the
way just attacking that's not bad okay
but Knight b6 rupee eight bishops e6b
texts six Quincy six Bishop d7 Quincy
seven rooty eight i don'ts don't believe
I'm winning that so let's go neither
three
yeah I need to use my development this
is the point very quickly taken that
that's quite surprising and it really
feels very risky that whole thing okay
night f 5 95 95 snot leading to much the
ship is protecting their quite reliably
now it cannot be better putting the
night there rookie one possible 96
therefore right I don't know but
thinking long probably does it help here
down by one minute oh he allows that
okay though f5 only 55 I guess in five
def five
yeah click very quickly here but it felt
very natural to to push this this
forward twin down okay show him what to
do oh it looks it looks nice but how am
I really getting anywhere substantial we
here for me six or something on 96 maybe
I could have gone night edge of plate 96
immediately of course why did they do
that some Quincy for and stuff like that
okay right a four is greedy um takes it
green eggs j 95 looks dangerous Quincy
for if I can get it in is pretty pretty
annoying so this check
so you're saying this is nothing really
94 f 6 time learning let's got queen
deform it's got Quinn deform
Queen f1 is 56 pretty awkward awkward
yeah maybe that it was awesome yeah
maybe he can defend all that stuff
possible 24 is really awful what am I
doing here my threatening stood
something 96 maybe I could have played
96 that was the move 96 Muslim shoot H
takes f tags and then I'm winning his
queen I mean it's not a clear thing at
all but this is this is the point I
should have done 96 yeah now I cannot
cannot really do anything anymore shoot
it should be too probably
now what a shame he shouldn't have he
shouldn't have get it going gotten away
with this stuff it was just far too
greedy and I just know g6 ah stupid
yeah complain even look h eight is
enough hmm nothing going on yes I go to
do is on time anyway here's am in the
position is lost yeah I just 96 96 check
check and logistics I just saw it too
late now okay this is easy i'm winning
the Queen so the only move is skinny aid
and then I mean it's quite obvious that
that this is dangerous yeah with the
King running around them the engine is
doing this and and claims it's a draw
with our petrol or repetition route is
six Queen THX Queen f8 Quincy for Queen
f6 back I'm interesting yeah that really
felt very dangerous and sublimity took
this so quickly anyway okay here here
Queen here and then F for a defend it as
well now maybe there wasn't many moves
he could play anyway but this is Queen
g5 look at for now a strong tending
route dd4 Wow ok so this dispute this
felt kind of normal okay i played this
to play you six and get get things going
check jinx now a queen is seven seems to
be still kind of okay if I check then
king of eight I like that Nyjah g6
tactic and here black isn't hacked
better according to the engine yeah this
this renders my capture wrong probably
this this is given by the computer Black
has to go f6 very unclear position
really certainly some kind of
compensation for white but is it better
for white food nobody knows okay well
thanks for watching